well so I tried to get Wayne Shorter to
Express sounds of the universe through
jazz through his saxophone okay so I
prepped him for a cosmic phenomenon to
see how he can he roll with it oh this
is going to be deep let's check it out I
want to describe something Astrophysical
to you and I'm wondering if you could
convert that to a musical expression in
the center of the Sun energy is created
by fusion and a photon of light is born
this photon of light careening back and
forth eventually escapes the Sun that
takes hundreds of thousands of years for
that photon to get from the center of
the Sun to a surface and it takes eight
minutes to get from the Sun to earth is
there music in that yeah okay can you
feel the photon trying to gain the
photon feel the foot I like that
feeling that's a that's an album title
right how you feeling approach ahaha
what the hold on fear is nothing okay
[Music]
and if I'm moving in any direction other
than that I think this one thing
incorporates all of the the movement and
struggles and everything like that and
all of the short-term goals and stuff
like that
the other people be looking for and this
photon is wrapping around that whole
thing but millions and millions and
years and something else is wrapping
around that and that's us
[Music]
okay now we know what people hate yeah
what the hell was did you see your face
in there
[Music]
you